there's not going to be a sequel yup you
can put your stilettos away because Anne
Hathaway just shut down the possibility
of a Devil Wears Prada Sequel and you
have no style or sense of fashion
well um
I think that depends on what you're you
know
that wasn't a question it's not gonna
happen it's just like we can't do it
it's not gonna happen it exists there
are other films there will be other
films we can just watch that one again
okay so maybe no sequel but the spirit
of Andy lives on at least a New York
Fashion Week yeah here's Anne last month
wearing a look that's nearly identical
to an outfit she wore in the Beloved
2006 film naturally the moment went
viral but Anne says it was purely an
accident I wish that I was this clever
wouldn't it if I I wish I I had this
kind of I don't know Machiavellian
tendency and I could like move all the
chess pieces and make you all feel how I
wonder the truth is it's just it was the
outfit that came the fit and that was
the best hairstyle for it and it turns
out people really like the Devil Wears
Prada it was a funny coincidence on the
way out the door I was like oh I wonder
if anybody will notice
no no really because because the thing
is it's like I don't stop and focus on
it but like it was a beautiful kind of I
think if anything it was just a
testament to people's love of the movie
and How Deeply they'd taken that film in
and that's just a wonderful feeling I
just feel lucky so Prada's in the past
and now Anne's focused on her latest
flick Armageddon time alongside Anthony
Hopkins
how dare you a menace to you
but you're not to associate with him
again what do you mean why
I think you know what I mean I think
it's always important to examine where
one Falls the world in everything the
world is into Fair perfect or sometimes
Pleasant place and I I think it really
falls on all of us to examine our own
contribution where we fall in the sort
of pecking order of things and figure
out if perhaps our Good Fortune is
because of our hard work or is because
we're actually leaning on someone a bit
too hard and I think it we should all
become comfortable with examining that
and I read someone react to this film
and they say it's a film about moral
regret
and I thought that was a really astute
take on it and sure Anne's worked with
the who's who in Hollywood but this film
had her geeking out on a whole new level
I was so oh my gosh oh my gosh I
I'm embarrassed I couldn't talk I mean
that's not a turn of phrase I could not
form words I couldn't remember my lines
I worked very hard on the accent that I
have in this film I couldn't do it I
just kind of ceased I was a completely
non-functional actor and he was so nice
about everything I don't even know that
he noticed but um
but then I I didn't want to miss out on
the experience with him but by feeling
bad or embarrassed about it so I just
kind of you know shook it off came back
the next day started talking that's when
I met Tony and it turns out he's an
amazing guy so wonderful so kind so open
so generous and he's a legend for a
reason and I got to see that firsthand
foreign